buenos días entonces sí claro que la
victoria la más que probable victoria de
manuel mayor es algo que se recibe con
mucho alivio en bruselas y en muchas
cancillerías europeas porque por
supuesto el proyecto europeo de emanuel
marco es mucho más cercano a lo que
defienden
bastantes de los líderes europeos
actuales en ese sentido claro que el
proyecto de ma jin lo pena era es mucho
más minoritario dentro de los dirigentes
europeos así que por supuesto eso va a
ser un refuerzo para la unión europea
dentro de dentro de lo que cabe porque
por supuesto una victoria de imagen lo
pena habría sido un terremoto en la
unión europea